kim kardashian reveals how her famous
family's new reality show will handle
her divorce from kanye west i'm rolling
with it the 41 year old skims founder
opens up in a new interview with variety
about the kardashians the fam's new hulu
series premiering april 14th you guys
it's happening
of course a lot has happened since
keeping up with the kardashians wrapped
in june 2021 it is what it is kim filed
for divorce from the 44 year old rapper
in february that year and the family's
e-series showed kim coming to terms with
the end of her marriage i just like i
honestly can't do this anymore
why am i still in this like place where
i'm stuck for years like he goes and
moves to a different state everywhere i
have to be like together so i can raise
the kids you know he's an amazing dad
he's done an amazing job the whole thing
he still will be since then kim and
kanye went from publicly supporting one
another like when the kkw beauty founder
rocked a balenciaga wedding gown for her
cameo during kanye's chicago danda event
in
[Applause]
to august feuding on social media with
yay hurling a series of accusations at
kim on instagram and trashing her new
beau saturday night live star pete
davidson
god sent me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis
now kim who shares four children with
the grammy winner tells variety that
fans shouldn't expect to see all the
behind the scenes drama on her new show
because she's respectful of what the
kids will see quote the reality is we're
always family we will always have a love
and respect for each other and even if
there's moments where it might not seem
like that there are so many moments that
are super positive i do have
you know a family that i have to just be
positive and get it together for the
makeup mogul says that having
disagreements publicly is never easy
adding quote i believe in championing
publicly and criticizing privately i
don't think i would ever criticize the
father of my children on my tv show
that's just not really what i'm about i
always believe and trust in him that he
will always eventually explain himself
because i know his heart
i will as of now and hopefully always
take the high road i love that energy in
my life and while kim may not be airing
all their dirty laundry she says quote i
do think it's important for people to
see that things aren't perfect all the
time but that they can get better adding
that fans will get to witness a lot of
their co-parenting journey something she
says will be really beautiful for people
to see at the end of the day life is
about being happy as for the future kim
says she's always hopeful we decided
that we always wanted to be really open
and honest to who we are when we would
film tough episodes that were really
about our life whether it was breakups
or
transitions or
things that other people might be having
a hard time dealing with at home if that
changed the way that reality tv is you
know viewed or seen as being really
helpful and informational i think that
makes me proud
[Music]